robert spencer you've got a new book
coming out tell us about
did muhammad exist yeah
uh this is the new revised and expanded
edition
of a book that i wrote back in 2010 or
11 or thereabouts
it contains 25 new material uh it's just
exactly what the title says did muhammad
exist is
an investigation of the uh origins of
islam and shows that
the historical records of muhammad and
of the beginnings of islam
are on much shakier foundations than
most people realize
since i first wrote it there have been
so many discoveries
in this field so many surprising things
for example a researcher dan gibson has
found that uh
a great many of the earliest mosques
don't point to mecca
for prayers uh you know muslims face
mecca all around the world to pray
but the original mosques did not face
mecca and as a matter
of fact there were no records that mecca
even existed until the 9th century
and no records of muhammad as we know
him as the prophet of islam
until around the same time well over 100
years after muhammad is supposed to have
died
the implications of this are
extraordinary it could be that
the whole of islam is built on a
essentially a fiction
a legend and uh on shifting sand the
but the did muhammad exist book is
essentially a historical inquiry that
looks into
the evidence and evaluates it on the
basis
of what we can know about muhammad which
really ends up being very little